thanks for uh
giving me an opportunity to
talk a little more about this stuff
um
let's just for a second have a show of
hands
who here has
ever seen a proof of shiro's lemma
not everyone among those voting who
raised their hand
was the proof that if you remember the
proof
is it the proof where you take a and b
and replace them by a union b and a
intersection b
or was it a different proof so who who
seems to recall seeing a proof where
there's this step where you
do some lag logs sub modularity or
something
okay so
that that was the proof of uh
shares lemon that i was first taught
20 something years ago
and
then jaikomar came and showed me the
correct proof
and really the the
i don't know if this was shiro's
original proof i couldn't find it online
i found
i couldn't find the paper online but
his original proof was
by induction on the number of times each
point is covered and that's
totally the wrong way to look at it
and
and if you know the right way then you
can it's easier to prove other things so
i wanted to show you a proof of the
fractional version of shira's lemma
which uses the which is just expanding
on the
on the book proof of sheer islam but
instead i'll just do a special case
which is what we
what we needed at this point in the talk
so let me
this is going to be a special case of
the fractional shearer and i'll
we'll see how easy it is to prove it if
you if you know how
so we had
a ground set and we had a family of sets
i j k l
and um
i wanted to impose some consistency
so i took my ground set and i covered it
i partitioned it into seven parts
and i called these four parts a script i
and these four parts i called script j
and these four parts i called script k
and uh
these four parts
are script l
and so
now uh
i'm only going to look
there's a sum here where you and
you you have sets i j k and l each one
of them gets a weight the weight is the
fourier coefficient
and we can assume that all the fourier
coefficients are are positive because
on this side of the inequality they're
squared
and
we can approximate them by rationals and
then we can clear a common denominator
so we can assume everything all the
weights here are integers
and uh
so this is supposed to be on sets i j k
l such that their symmetric differences
the empty set meaning
four sets such that
if you look at their union every point
there is covered an even
number of times
but i'm going to restrict only to sets
which are consistent with this partition
so if you tell me that i union j union k
union l is this
then i already know what i is i is this
and j is this and
so i'm only looking at sets such that if
you look at the venn diagram of those
sets
each part of the venn diagram those sets
falls in a corresponding part of the big
venn diagram so i'm going to restrict
only
to those sums and then i have to show
this strange inequality if you restrict
to those quadruples
take the square it's less than
the product of these four
sums
sum of
f i squared fj squared of k squared of l
squared and here's how we're going to do
just it they're just
positive integers
and
what we're going we'll take the log of
both sides and i'll show you the log of
the left hand side
is twice the entropy of something
so
we're going to define that something
and then twice the entropy of that
something is going to be less than the
sum of four other entropies the entropy
of something coming from here plus the
entropy of something coming and so on
and those four entropies will they won't
be necessarily equal to the log of the
right hand side but they'll bound it
from below and that'll show us that the
right hand side is greater than the left
hand side
so what are our
uh random variables
and let's just say for the sake of this
talk that
i
if you go over the elements of i you
have 1 and then you have 2 and then you
have 17 and then you have other
so script i
is 1 2 17 and some other things
so
here here's my
random variable the random variable i'm
going to look at
is
of the form x
c i
c j
c k
c l
what what are these and what
what are these exactly so
first of all i have x1 up to xn
x
has is a binary vector of length n and
this is just the
characteristic vector
of some
consistent
uh i union j
union k
union l
so
i
what values can this random variable
take
for every uh i j k now which are
consistent i look at their union and i
take the characteristic vector of their
union so that's they're in coordinates
they tell us for each element in the
ground set whether it's in the union or
not and then
ci is just going to be
belongs to so i have this
and then
ci is just going to
belong to the set
1 up to
f hat of i
of which i i have x
so
once i know x
i know the i union j union k union l i
also know what i is
once i know what i is
i i let c i be an integer between 1 and
f hat of of i
and
the same with c of j c of k and c of l
okay so now
it's clear what
what how large is the support of this uh
random variable it can go over
all quadruples and for each quadruple
i have the freedom i have for c i c j c
k c l is precisely this
so that's that's the size what's written
here
is the size of the support
so
if i take this
uh uniformly over the support
then
what i promised you is true the log of
the left-hand side is precisely twice
the entropy of this random variable
okay
now
what about the
squared right yeah i take the log i get
twice the log of this twice the log of
the size of the support
and the c i is determine the x's
no the x is determining the c i's once i
know the x
x's
i know i union j union k union in l
and i should have used colored marker
for this and once i know the union
i also know the projections
so once i know x
i know i i know j and okay no l okay but
it's important that uniform on the
product of those things right
yeah i said
here i'm just telling you what values it
can take
and then i'm saying i'm taking uniform
on all values that it can take
so then the entropy is just the log of
the size of the support
and what you said is true the
the size is well this is the size
what's inside the brackets here
okay what
um
what do i have on the right hand side
what what a
what random variables am i going to use
here i'm going to use the following
random variables
so
uh
i'm writing x restricted
to script i
so this is just i take this vector x1 up
to xn but i only look at its
projection on script i so i only look at
the coordinates in script i
okay
so um
so i have
this is the definition of x-script i
take this long vector and look at the
window corresponding to the elements in
script i
and then i have
something i call ci
superscript one
and ci
scr superscript two
and this is my random variable
and what are
what are these two uh
um
what are these two random variables
they're just
copies of this ci so
when i know the value of x restricted to
i
then i know
what i am talking about and then i let
then i take two random variables
that conditioned on on
on the fact that i know i already they
um
their their conditional distribution is
just uniform on
one up to fi
each one of them is
uniform and one up to fi or the pair is
uniform and one up to fi squared
and now
and now i i i have to i have to say two
things first of all
why
and i do the same thing for jk and l so
why is this true why is the entropy of
these four things bigger than twice the
entropy of this
and y
so this is y one
no this is y two and this is y one so
this is question one question two so a
question one i made it one because it's
very easy
uh
you see
oh i did this i told you what values
this random variable takes but i didn't
tell you it's distribution
the distribution is as follows i take x
uniform
from here and then i look at the the
at the projection on these eye
coordinates so of course
the the
the size of the support
is this
so it can it goes over all possible eyes
and for each one you still have this
uh degree
f hat of i squared choices to make
and but why is it not equal to
why is the log of this not why is the
entropy of this not equal to the log
it's just bounded by because it's not
necessarily uniform okay if it was if it
was uniform then so the largest it can
be is uh is the log of this if it's
uniform but perhaps it's smaller
so that
that answers question number one
and now we reach the uh
the crux of the whole proof uh question
number two and
what i haven't used here is the
part of the hypothesis of
shear slam or the fractional shearer's
lemma and that every point should be
covered t times and here t is equal to
two
so
when we take when we look at our ground
set
every point in our ground set is covered
by at least two
of the sets script i script j script k
script l and now i'm going to use that
how am i going to use that
um if i write the entropy of
the entropy of x
c i
c j
c k
c l
it's equal to
h of x one
plus h of x two
given x one
plus dot dot plus
h of x seventeen
given
x one up to x sixteen
plus dot dot all the way to h of
x n
given
all x's with index smaller than n
plus um
uh yeah plus
the um
entropy of ci
given x
plus the entropy of cj given x plus the
okay so this is
and let's put a 2 here
twice
so everything has a 2 2 2
2
2 2. okay that's that's twice the
entropy of this random variable now what
happens when i expand this random
variable
when i take h of
x restricted to script i
comma c i 1
c i 2
that's equal to well let me use the
chain rule for x script i
this is
h of x one
ah okay so that cancels one of the two
copies of x h of x one that i had plus
h of x x2 given x1
great that
cancels another copy here plus now comes
a subtle point
h of x17
given x1 and x2
because i'm i'm only
i'm only looking at the coordinates of x
which are in script i
ah here i have x of 17 conditioned on
all the
a
coordinates up to 16. here i have it
conditioned only on some of them the
more i condition on the less entropy is
left
so h of x 17 given x 1 and x 2 is
greater than h of x 17 given x 1 up to x
6
16. so this cancels this easily so it
brings it down from 2 to 1.
and then i continue and then i have h
of
c i
copy 1 given
x a restricted to i
plus the entropy of
c i
2
restricted to
a conditioned on x restricted to i
and i say okay
here i have the entropy of ci
conditioned on x
but the only thing that in x which
affects
the
uh
the entropy of ci is the coordinates in
in i so here i i'm i'm conditioning on
less and here it's actually equal so i
have
two of these copies and they they cancel
out these two
so it seems i'm
i'm off to a good start but then i say
oh i've only
i've only canceled out one copy of h of
x one how am i going to cancel the other
one out i say okay i was now i was only
doing a i but one also belongs to l so
when i do the random variable that
corresponds to l
then i'll get to
it'll dominate the second copy of h of
x1 and so on and so forth every element
that appears there i'll get to treat it
twice if not four times so
this answers
this question and that's
so that's that's the proof of
the fractional shearer's lemma that's
how the proof goes and and this is just
a
small generalization of the
what
is the correct proof of shiro's lemma
okay so
that's what i wanted to say about this
just i'll remind you the context in
which we were talking about this
was that when you take
i i wanted i wanted the this sum not
only
with respect to one partition but
i i wanted to drop the
condition it's a consistent with this
partition and then i said okay if you
take a random partition
then you're getting some
the ratio between what you see here and
what you really want to
uh evaluate is bounded
but it turns out that the bound is
exponential in the size of the set so
the sets are size m
you get some bound which is exponential
and m
and if you remember
what we were proving
so this this is what we were proving
we're comparing the forum to the two
norm and you and if the
if the sets in question the support of
the fourier transform was of size m you
pay some
something which is exponential and then
okay so that
that was the first thing i wanted to
talk about
and
the second thing i want are there any
questions about this
yeah
so
so you had this inequality for a fixed
partition right
you wanted to turn that into an
inequality without fixed partitions yes
so i have to count how many times each
if i have a
smaller set is the more more times it
appears right
no all the sets are i j k and l are of
size m
but then i for a fix you give me four
fixed sets i j k l i have to count how
many partitions they participated in
and uh
and i forget the exact
calculation but but
the answer is
so this is
what it's not a constant
no it's something that depends on them
it's something
exponential in them
what should appear here is
is uh
so
square root 3 to them
but this is somehow
a wasteful procedure and gives you
a non-optimal constant
okay any other questions about this
good okay then
um
second thing i wanted to talk about was
uh
the slides i rushed through yesterday
okay so
this is this is uh these are the two ver
okay what's on the bottom
is the true version of of
beckner's inequality the bonomi
grossbeckner inequality that i want to
prove
you have two vectors x and y which are
epsilon correlated so y is a noisy
version of x
and
you look at the expectation of f of x
times g of y
f and g are non-negative functions
and
the claim is it's it's bounded by uh
the one plus epsilon norm of f times the
one plus epsilon norm of g
and
maybe it's it's easier to
to understand it intuitively if you look
at the boolean case so if f and g are
just the
indicator functions of some um
of some set so x is the indicator
of uh
f is the indicator of script x and
g is the indicator of script
y then because
there is some correlation between x and
y
you expect that
perhaps
if you can choose x and y such that the
probability of x falling in script x and
y following script y
is slightly bigger than
the measure of x times the measure of y
so it's slightly bigger than what you'd
get if they were independent
but but this tells you that it's not
much bigger so if you take a number less
than one and you raise it to a power
less than one you're
increasing that number but it tells you
if you increase this by this much then
then
it already dominates this so it gives
you some
measure of how how much you can make
these two things correlate
okay so let's let's see
more or less what what we have to do to
prove this
and how
going from this to this is just
one
small more one more small step
for men
um
okay so
what what we're going to do is something
similar to here
we're going to
have some inequality and have
entropy of something on the left-hand
side entropy of something on the
right-hand side but
unfortunately this time to show
this
you have to solve some calculus problem
and show that indeed this is greater
than this so it comes it's more ugly
it's not
it's not that elegant um so let's see
what
so here's what we want to prove so i
just i write this out the expectation of
this so i go over every x
give it weight 2 to the n then for every
x i go over every y
and i give it some weight depending on
how how many coordinates it agrees with
x and how many disagrees
so
and then
you know i take the log of both sides
and i
cancel terms and i get something like
this
so
here's some expression
a of x and y is how many coordinates
they agree b is how many coordinates
they disagree
and you want to give a prize if they
agree and a fine if they disagree
and this is what you get and then
once again i want to
approximate everything by rationals and
then clear common denominators i want to
have integers so i'll have
support of some random variable so after
you
so this is what you get after you clear
the
uh
the common denominators
where r and s depend on epsilon somehow
s over r plus s is one minus epsilon
over two and r over r plus s is one plus
epsilon over two so you get something
like this
and then
then okay now we can start defining our
random variables and and
it's sort of clear what random variable
you have to choose for the right hand
side for the left hand side
so
i'm going to choose a random variable
xyz
and i'll tell you what the support is
and it's going to be
i'll take it uniform on the support and
then its entropy will be the log of the
size of the sport so
what i need is that x is in script x
y
is in script y
and now
i'm going to define
four sets
a zero zero is a set of size
r
a one one
is a set of size r
a one zero is a set of size s
and a zero one
is a set of size s
and
z so x and y
everything here belongs to zero once
then
and uh zi
is
uh
always belongs to a of
x i y i
so
if um
if x i is one and y i is zero
then z i has to belong to a one zero so
given the fact that the
x
x i is one and y is zero z is
distributed on some set of size s
and s is smaller than r so whenever they
agree you get something
you get more entropy and whatever they
disagree you get less entropy
and
and that that defines what the support
of this random variable is and its
support the size this is exactly the
size of the support
okay
so the entropy of that random variable
is the log of
uh
is the log of this now
uh on this side i'm going to have
i'm going to look at the same x and y
i'll take them from this distribution
so i'm taking x and y
note that if if this is if this is
uniform x if x y z is uniform it forces
x and y to be epsilon correlated it it
means that it's more likely
to get
x i equal to y i than x i different from
y i because r is greater than s
so
i'm going to take the the conditional
distribution of x and y
and those are going to be
this is going to be
greater than h of x and this is going to
be greater than h of y
and then i'm going to use the chain rule
so let's see what it
okay so
what the the h of z is going to be equal
to the left hand side
and on the right hand this is supposed
to be less or equal to the right hand
side
and i'm going to use the chain rule i'm
going to look at it bit by bit
and
i'll hope that every bit that i expose
here while when i do the chain rule i
have the condition of what
i um what i've seen so far
we're hoping that the conditional
distribution is still such that the
entropy of the next bit of zi
is
less or equal to well we have n steps
here in every step we get this factor
plus
something times the entropy of the next
bit of x in the next bit of y i
and so
using the chain rule
um
okay you so using the chain rule this is
what we have to prove
i mean at this point
as i told you yesterday
i knew i had to be lucky because it it
doesn't have to be
true bit by bit it could be that on
average it's true if it was true on
average i think this proof would be
even worse
but luckily it's true
regardless of the
of the past
and um
and then okay i want to get rid of this
z so i
i write h of z
as h of x y plus h of z given x y
and that makes z go away
and then i get some expression in in x
and y
and and also there's another thing
just believe me that if i uh
multiply r and s by any
it only depends on the ratio between r
and s if i multiply r and s by constant
this expression that i want to show that
is non-negative stays the same
so
here's the calculus problem you get you
have
a distribution this is the joint
distribution of x i and y i
and you have to prove this that enthalpy
of x plus the entropy of y times
something
minus the joint entropy
and then you get some additional factor
that comes from the case when x is
different than y
uh the case when a x is equal to y was
multiplied by log one so it disappeared
and okay and now this is a calculus
problem and
okay so you do some you have to dirty
your hands a bit but not too much
because everything is very nicely
symmetric so you use the lagrange
multipliers you get some expressions
and then you start
you you start
looking what's the best way to
utilize them and
and so
one last thing i have two more minutes
that i'll say is that it's sort of
it
it's slightly intimidating to solve this
unless you already knew what you're
looking for
where i know that in beckham's
inequality the it's only
it would only be equal
when um
script x equals script y equals
everything
in that case
x i would be
distributed half half between zero and
one what y i would also be
uniform on zero and one but they'd be
epsilon correlated
and then you'd get this distribution so
if you know what the minimum is
it's easier to try to show that the
these constraints um
imply that that the minimum has to look
like that
so okay you you play around with a bit a
bit i'm going to skip those details
and
last thing i want to say is what about
non-boolean functions
so
if
when you have non-boolean functions you
have to you have to add on
another two coordinates to z to x y z
uh instead of x y z it's sort of similar
to what we did here you have x y z a and
b where a
is uniform on one up to f of x b is
uniform on one up to g of y
and
and you have to see what how that
changes the entropy on the left hand
side and on the right hand side and
luckily because
you have some kind of majin homogeneity
that
this power is one over this
somehow it works out that what you add
to the left hand side is exactly
what you get on the right hand side
you use
use this
this
nice fact if you have the entropy of x
and you have the expectation of log of
any function of x
that's less or equal to
the log the sum of the log of that
function on all of x so
that's that's the fact that's easy to
prove and using that fact you see that
the contributions on the left-hand side
and the right-hand side by adding these
two extra coordinates are the same
so
you go from boolean to non-boolean just
in two lines and that's it
okay that's all i have to say